welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons here to break down
episode nine aka the finale of She-Hulk
for you this episode it was so much so
much happened so many new crazy
appearances I guess everyone's a dad now
in the MCU there's Daddy's Galore Jen
could change Kevin's creation which
means maybe Deadpool can too now like
let's just get into it because I'm still
spiraling oh my God what did we just
watch before the Marvel logo and song
stop the Marvel Studios logo starts to
Twitch and frizz out a red screen reads
danger and it's mimicking the 1978
opening to The Hulk TV series frame for
Frank and now we also see the scene from
the trailer of 70s Jen and Bruce and
where it came from we also get the same
image of a meal they used in the earlier
episodes on the news that we know is
from The Incredible Hulk when Jen
transforms into She-Hulk in this intro I
think it's the onset She-Hulk reference
Malia Aria I might be wrong but it might
be her Jen working on her computer with
her mug I also think resembles the
courtroom illustration we see with her
in the shield files at the end of every
episode the narrator refers to her as
the Savage She-Hulk a call back to the
Savage She-Hulk comics from the 80s this
is the first run of She-Hulk where
through a lot of turmoil Jen becomes a
Hulk almost dies does permanently decide
to be a She-Hulk and a lot of stuff just
happens also they call it Savage
She-Hulk because she's a Saiyan
this all could have been Jen dreaming
though because she wakes up in the same
prison Emil was in in Prior episodes
episode two and three to be exact at the
dodc Mallory pug and Nikki like the
great friends they are checking in on
Jen and reveal to her a plea deal she
has to wear an inhibitor we've seen the
inhibitor before we've seen it with Hulk
we've seen it with a meal and now Jen
has it which you know clearly sucks
because we know from episode 3 a meal
can still change into abomination in
that cell and even clearly mad talking
to Mallory about it Jen doesn't change
into She-Hulk she can clearly control
her anger this is also sort of mirrors
everything that happened to a Mill and
out of control moment witnessed by
others furthering the notion that you're
still a walking Hazard so Jen starting
right now has relinquished her ability
to change back into She-Hulk which sucks
we begin the sort of Montage of Jen's
life kind of flopping her mom and dad
hugging her outside of the prison he's
now lost her job and the news is all
over it we have kpv k-15 news Los
Angeles now kzyo12 who called this
galagate like because Gala gay it's a
player on the infamous Watergate we've
seen each news Outlet in earlier
episodes all three appeared in the
beginning of episode 2 covering the
She-Hulk and Titania courtroom debacle
we've also seen this news track from the
trailers and then the same scene of them
yelling to Jen from the window Jen has
now moved out of her very amazing Suite
apartment after hearing from what her
mom and dad just said previously I think
a I don't think she can afford it
because she has no job now and B the
paparazzi are constantly hounding her
she needs a break we spent so much time
in this home and it's so sad to see it
go like this once Jen arrives at her
parents house we see the kcav 35 news
van we saw in episode three a ton of
reporters one looks like the reporter
from the third episode that we've seen
as well luckily Jen's dad is there to
shoe them away with a garden hose even
with Morris commenting on not caring if
there's a drought because California is
always in a drought the first thing we
see in Jen's old room is the Legally
Blonde poster which probably is my
favorite Lawyer movie I I'm not joking
we've also got Julia Roberts's Julia
Roberts's Julia Roberts Aaron Brockovich
movie poster another Lawyer movie the
UCLA Bruins Banner which yes we know in
the comics she went to UCLA but in the
first episode we also see her degree so
we know she graduated from it here too
some photos with family and friends of
course the workout equipment her mom a
mancala game on the Shelf award ribbons
A Midsummer's Night Dream poster with
Puck on the cover Backstreet Boys black
and blue album poster oh yeah baby it's
everyone's old bedroom in our parents
house that they just never touched truly
once we moved out so Jen has begun to
Pepe Sylvia her way into figuring out
and deducing who the Intelligentsia
really is Jesus Christ that right there
so we see lion day one Hulk King Emoji
he's the admin around him are trace
phone calls and a post describing how
She-Hulk is a radical to the left we see
a man whom I assume is a part of the
intelligentia his middle name is Van
last name win they got the man's social
security number and everything so they
delve really deep we see sticky notes
citing the intelligence he was
originally banned on two sites and
inevitably made their own right here his
image links to the intelligencio which
links to a black bird-like face a green
sword a moth and a panda a weird Chicken
Boy we know the Pepe frog looking
cartoon is Hulk King I think the black
one could be the wizard or Trapster both
members of the intelligence and the
comics because the eyes remind me of
goggles the green moth-like one could be
Iron moth a really silly villain in the
comics or Civil War act AKA gypsy moth
the panda icon is definitely Panda guy
we see later commenting on she-hul's
Dancing clip the Chicken Boy could be
big from the comics I've mentioned him
in the past assuming one of Luke
Jacobson's costumes could be from his
episode in episode 5 or this could be a
homage to Dick organ spoof on comic book
hero from the 60s mainly making fun of
Batman screen Crush thinks this horned
one could be Mandrill who has been
problematic in a lot of comics if you
zoom out there's actually a gorilla or
ape at the top so that could also be
mandrel the intelligentia is allegedly
owned by several shell companies that
are operating outside of the US
jurisdiction a shell company is a
company or corporation that exists only
on paper and has bank accounts funding
different assets or just withholding
money we know in season three episode
five of Daredevil fiscu shell
corporations to purchase the hotel he
was staying in and that Julie was
working at sneaky sneaky you remember
Dennis Bukowski right who thought he was
dating Megan the stallion in episode
three yeah the idiot now he's on the
conversation with Jefferson Coop who
we've also seen in episode three Dennis
is talking about Jen and their past
relationship being in a relationship
he's clearly lying but not in like a
good way either he just looks stupid he
said I blame her grandmother so we know
Jen's mom is Elaine and Elaine's mom is
Beatrice Banner who was married to
Robert Stearns but slept with his
brother Samuel Stearns and then was
disavowed by that brother Robert Stearns
it just all went crazy and Robert ended
up killing his brother so unless he's
calling back to that I I think Dennis is
just spilling some BS Jen could be
talking to herself she could be breaking
the fourth wall here when she asks if
this is what we wanted I felt like a
child watching Dora the Explorer going
no I'm violently shaking my head we get
the narrators like 70s intro coming back
and she acknowledges you can have a
narrator only when you're going off the
rails which is sort of true if you
remember that scene in Emperor's New
Groove she text Hulk AKA smug Hulk on
her phone the messages don't go through
same with her text to a mill because
they both don't have service in both
places one's in space and one's on a
retreat with no Wi-Fi Jen goes through
her phone and we see some names like
Ethan Rudy Jordan Robin these people are
all people that could potentially when I
look them up work for different parts in
Marvel but I also think they're just a
list of random names and people that
she's dated in the past like Robin says
next time you're in Vancouver come visit
Ken R says fun time Noah says Darby is
the one for you who we see a clip of in
episode 3 this could possibly be Darby
don't care who was talking major-ish on
She-Hulk we got Grant who's just Rick
Rolling us Rick I just want to tell you
how I see it I think we're just getting
more kind of Rick rolls a lot of these
folks are friends and men that she's
gone on dates with and talked to briefly
so it's just good to mention it Nikki
uploads Jen dancing like a little dummy
in college to the intelligencia website
as bait for the annoying baby men who
hate her if this doesn't remind you of
everyone attacking AOC when she was
dancing in college you are not catching
on baby because this video is and I
quote an epic find Mickey immediately
gets invited to the Hulk king of vet
happening that night the same night Jen
arrives at a meals Retreat hmm what
could possibly go wrong when Nikki and
the Hulk King are talking both usernames
are not a mouse which is used when you
want to be completely Anonymous on
online forums or just distribute
information super anonymously
anonymously Jen arrives at the Twilight
Summers to an immediate welcome from the
wrecker who I expected to be up to
something but as we find out later I
don't think he is not a disappointment
but I was wrong and I can admit when I'm
wrong he sets her up with a guest room
and a copy of deep haikus by Emile
Blonsky and in the second episode Emil
Royal haikus to each of his victims
expressing sorrow so I wonder who this
one's for before I go any further I just
want to say be sure to head over to new
rockstarsmerch.com and grab our latest
Obsession shirt Lady Justice inspired by
the She-Hulk attorney at law series
along with our Daredevil Devil's
Advocate shirt the instructor limited
edition and when you purchase it you
unlock the ability to get a custom shout
out that would appear on the show that
comes out usually the day before my show
inside Marvel support the channel and
check out all of our awesome merch
options over at New rockstarsmerch.com
before it's out hurry go shoot come back
come back okay thank you on the other
hand of things pug and Nikki arrive to
the event and rightfully to play the
part Nikki tells pug to blend in and
only refer to women as females because
just don't do it don't do it it's
horrible as soon as we enter the event
there's a sign that says big men dream
big and the same fun as the motivational
posters for a Mill's Retreat and I'm
like seriously even with the same Obama
stay Swag like damn Emil you don't need
their money that bad I swear to God also
this is the same place they held the
group therapy and gives reason now to
all of those foldable chairs that
She-Hulk threw the record into as pug
listens to a group of idiots Converse
station we overhear them already
fighting about the name She-Hulk which
is no surprise there that they don't
recognize a man coined it in the second
episode they also mentioned lady Thor
AKA Jane Foster we do know that Jane had
been lady Thor longer than what we saw
in Thor 11 Thunder but Valkyrie says
he's only been doing it for a minute so
it probably wasn't that long after but
it does confirm that She-Hulk overlaps
with it none other than the stupid idiot
buttface himself Todd shows up not
surprising I think we all knew that he
was a part of the intelligence I mean
he's a butthead I think we all expected
him to be here but in like the most
offensive way he's not surprised to see
pug there and Pug's heart literally
crumbles also when Todd is like pug
rules and he's hot a voice in the
background goes yeah I'd smash you and
another goes wait what it killed me I
loved it he rules and he's hot
for John bass who plays Todd this is the
most we've got from him in terms of
motivation so Kudos but as Todd I want
to hit him upside this head we see his
justification that Jen was given her
powers handed these powers from Hulk who
is given no credit which though Todd
clearly doesn't know an ounce of the
true story is pissed by about it he also
reveals himself to be Hulk King which no
doy we know Todd and we sort of
confirmed Holden Holloway has nothing
wrong or ill wishes upon Jen or at least
as far as the Intelligentsia goes
because Todd suspects Holden and Jen are
hooking up which gross Todd winds these
guys up kicking in the air like an
aggressive weird Ted Talk he will keep
that scarf on forever and I want to
choke him with it behind him is the
achieve everything saying Emil has and a
picture of what I assume is a meal
meditating upon a hill silhouetted when
Rucker and Jen are talking Rucker
mentioned Sarah since puera T which is
traditionally fermented tea from China
that's great for lowering your
cholesterol and improving your health
but saracen slips in chicken blood
because basically he's a vampire if you
remember from episode 7. hmm
kind of missed the chicken Blood by the
way hunting for Easter eggs in your
favorite show or movie that's fun
hunting for malware or an old system
logs on your Mac Oh horrible that's a
job you want done for you which is why
there's clean my Mac X clean my Mac X is
the best software on the market to clean
and optimize your Mac it deletes Mega
tons of junk malware uninstalls unused
apps which I severely need and makes Mac
computers faster safer and more
organized it's so good that it's been
notarized by Apple themselves and if
it's notarized by Apple you know it's
good and if anybody knows how to keep a
Mac clean it's probably the people that
build it I assume right I mean I hope
clean my Mac X has a whole bunch of
tools you can use to clean up your Mac
smart scan finds system files you no
longer need space lens will show you
what files are taking up the most room
on your hard drive and malware removal
will find all those nasty little viruses
and junk programs you didn't even know
you had the little ones that go like
it's like little rats it's like rats and
once your Mac is healthy clean my Mac
X's menu app will help you keep it
healthy by giving you an easy way to
look at Key performance indicators of
your computer because God knows I don't
understand what's going on no wonder
clean my Mac X has been an industry
leader in Mac health for 14 years and
he's used by millions of people and 185
countries around the world plus
Antarctica I guess they don't normally
count to get started making your Mac run
like new just click the link in the
description to download clean my Mac X
today peep The Wrecking Crew in the back
right now maybe I was wrong about
wrecker maybe he left the group
rightfully so but his team is still a
part of the Intelligentsia and this is
the scene we saw from the trailer of a
mill high-fiving all those men the song
playing is gonna be a winner performed
by Jason Glover and Richard Neal and
this does feel like a life coaching
seminar it really does feel like that
when Jen enters I like that she doesn't
care about Todd the men all weirdly
cheering or the event at all just a meal
changing into Abomination because she's
still his lawyer and she cares about him
Nikki slams open the garage door
announcing Todd is impact the Hulk King
who learned that Todd paid for Josh to
seduce and steal Jen's blood in episode
seven and his team worked on it
synthesizing it allowing Todd to take it
he then takes the blood and turns into a
Hulk taught which is the most cartoony
Scrappy dude hulking out I've ever seen
since the Scooby-Doo movie Titania
arrives again smashing through a wall
and I love Nikki's line here God does
that fish ever use a door Bruce arrives
smashing through the ceiling and
immediately in a misunderstanding starts
fighting a meal Jen breaks the fourth
wall noticing none of these storylines
make sense which is true everything is
popping in out of everywhere and I swear
to God I thought my computer was conking
out when it took me back to the Disney
plus Marvel screen and The Sensational
She-Hulk Comics Jen stepped out of the
comic box to start a fight with the
writer which is completely the same not
Racine done on the Marvel page he swings
from shun Chi and the 10 rings to Loki
and jumps into Marvel assembled which is
funny because now it's featuring a
thumbnail of Thor love and thunder but
at the time She-Hulk was imposed
probably featuring Sean Chi this is when
it goes off the rails because she now
knows the other shows and movies that
appear on Disney plus she's aware of her
story being a portion of a larger a
threat either way we're brought to the
Disney lot in Burbank California once
Jen landed on set we saw this bit in the
trailer but they edited out all the
production equipment so clearly we
didn't know also two men are discussing
the first Thor movie and having to make
thanos's Gauntlet during the first Thor
movie referring to the fake one that we
saw the Disney water tower the Seven
Dwarves holding up the roof the old wise
tale is that the Seven Dwarfs are
holding up the roof because that's what
kind of started Disney that was like the
first feature film for Disney Walt and
Mickey in the middle of the courtyard
along with the two on the bench the
Disney Legends handprints all over the
walls of different artists we see our
weekly QR code on the She-Hulk door it
takes you to a free copy of The
Sensational She-Hulk 1989 issue number
50 also Pete the Captain America poster
in the back the same one we've seen in
the first Captain America movie but
these posters are telling you to silence
your phones which I think is really
funny and in an amazingly weird wild
freaking scene we see the Riders from
shiho going over the next season and oh
my God this is fun this was also Kevin
feige's idea we have the Captain America
poster slightly different crafty snack
tax on the wall are different types of
photos for Titania and LeapFrog we see a
man bull the demons portrayed in the
fourth episode on the Whiteboard it says
finale with a four-leaf clover now
recently I found out that all the words
on the Whiteboard are things that Zeb
Wells says during pitching in the
writer's room so they just put all their
favorite phrases that he said on that
wall so all of these lists are just
things that Zeb has said who's aka the
ham guy and the credits I'll get into
that in a second he I guess coined
enchantable Hulk which we see at the
wedding episode in episode 6 all over
ched shirt and the DJ equipment Nanobots
Exclamation point Exclamation point in
the comics Iron Man injected She-Hulk
with Nanobots that inhibit her power
things like here you're not allergic to
wowies but there's no wowie at the end
which could refer to our big climax as
being wowies gamma gu but I think I like
it more if it's kind of like gabagool
and it's gamma ghoul we've got a Hulk
poster that says smash and Shred let's
also not do real from the casting
because oh my God the blonde lady at the
top could be Winnie Jacobson the co-ep
on She-Hulk and the red is Jessica gal
the Creator and head writer she hold the
man behind her is credited as the ham
guy you can't really see it but he's
carving a ham now this guy is Michael
Zeb Wells a writer and producer for
She-Hulk and he also wrote Amazing
Spider-Man run of comics he actually has
written a lot of comics he's a great
writer also we get a snippet of Cody
Ziggler who is one of the staff writers
for the series The Two writers that are
non-stop talking are actually actors
portraying Jessica gal and Zeb Wells
Eden Lee and Justin miles which is very
funny to me that they just didn't use
the actual writers behind gen we see the
visual designs they picked from not to
different Comics we see the battle of
the Inhumans cover She-Hulk issue number
26 and her Infamous leotard outfits they
refer to Kevin feige I assume this is
Kevin feige as k-e-v-i-n and I am not
gonna say the acronym I'm gonna say
Kevin because I feel like me and this
robot would be close which we later find
out stands for knowledge enhanced visual
interconnectivity Nexus and we've heard
the term Nexus millions of times before
and the Marvel is Cinematic Universe we
follow Jen through the Marvel Studios
Corridor an elevator and the space-like
wallpaper you can see the Marvel studio
sign behind it but opposite of the
elevator is actually the Guardians of
the Galaxy we see a black panther poster
next to the She-Hulk poster and the
office waiting area we see a Hulk statue
The Infinity Gauntlet various Marvel
action figures including the tiny Thanos
on his little chair on the table we see
Tony Stark's suits his Mark 2 5 and 7
suits the receptionist is actually
played by Matt Wilkie who at the time
worked as Marvel Studios as the
receptionist because they thought it
would be fun for you to be like that's
the guy that actually signed me in and
told me to sign the NBA speaking of ndas
you have to sign the non-disclosure
agreement because uh it's Marvel dude
they're not gonna let you leak their
secrets without signing the NDA then Q
energy by lotto and We're Off to the
Races baby Jen is beating up every
Marvel security Personnel in her way I
like this hallway fighting scene because
it's giving me Daredevil fighting scene
and I'm like ooh they're getting closer
we see the hallways line with Stills and
different Marvel property images I think
these are all original concept art we
see rocket and Star-Lord from Guardians
of the Galaxy Thor's hammer and the Arc
Reactor from Iron Man once we make it to
Kevin's let's call it an office we see
clips from Civil War and Infinity War
Multiverse and Madness black panther
Thor Ragnarok end game Avengers
separately Age of Ultron some of these
clips show up in the opening sequence to
a Marvel movie but not all of them and
in a spooky reveal we find out Kevin is
a robot a very smart sentient robot
that's been creating these Marvel shows
and movies also his hood for his camera
eyes resemble like a little hat and I
love it according to Jessica gal they at
first toyed around with a human playing
Kevin they were actually looking at like
James Hamm James Hand what's his name
but turning him into a robotic machine
just made more sense and was funnier
also I know that people want Jon Hamm to
play Mr Sinister so let's just leave it
at that this reveal completely reminded
me of the Wally scene when we realized
the robot was actually crazy and very
evil I also really like this gag that
She-Hulk has been going on sort of
poking fun at Marvel things in an
interview Jessica gow said that they had
to cut a lot of their jokes out of the
series because they poke too much fun at
Marvel but making Kevin feigen an
all-powerful all-knowing robot that the
writers obey and pray to is funny and
true to all of us and Kevin is built so
interestingly he has three lenses each
red blue green RGB primary colors of
light used in a lot of video formats
color TV even he has two sort of floppy
disk drives upon his head which is why
and on and off switch which I'm sure is
not in use the screen on the side I can
make out says Kevin but I think it's
tracking which lens it's using either
way it's font and format kinda looks
like the TV is used in Loki and also
when you get to a wider view you see a
full film spool continuously spinning
it's insane and Kevin acknowledges the
vfx's expensive citing gen must change
off screen so easy so fun though he does
go off and say that the VFX artists have
moved on to different projects when he
says that we hear the wakanda drums
indicating it was probably to move those
VFX folks over to the wakanda forever
during the time of shooting this I mean
or it's a nod to The Plight that the VFX
Folks at Disney whom they usually
Outsource have been dealing with for a
while being overworked and underpaid I
calls it as a season we also get shots
of these podiums filled with different
Marvel comic books it feels like Kevin
is sort of absorbing them the bottom of
the podiums look like electric currents
though it could actively be always
reading these Comics I'm no Ryan Airy I
never would say I am he he reads
everything who I'm sure went in depth on
each of these Comics but I damn will try
Ryan okay so I think we see America
Chavez's comic book a She-Hulk comic
book and a Scarlet Witch we got the Miss
Marvel Captain America The Incredible
Hulk and Daredevil shun Chi and I think
that's Sam Wilson's Captain America what
I do sort of like is that as opposed to
most MCU movies or shows that have these
giant climaxes with explosions fights
and sometimes the super soldier serum
this could be the first to break that
deal with the internal conflict that Jed
has while everyone else's Stakes may
include rampaging and Powers Jens is
fighting herself and overcoming all that
stuff that happened here so yeah
different Stakes can work and I like
that Kevin took that into account so now
Todd's Hulk powers are removed Hulk does
not save the day and Jen's show but Jen
does interject and say save it for the
movie which every avenger who has a
family has now gained like a movie
there's like Thor I'll argue Wanda and
now Hulk and I don't think it's
necessarily A get a child get a movie
deal but we need to see our Avengers
that haven't died move on as we
introduce some newer ones coming in as
Jen is addressing her needs I love that
Kevin begins to acknowledge that some
can see as a fault on the MCU for being
light in that department referring to
sex Jen immediately sits down starts
listing off all her quarrels after that
and I love this she addresses all the
daddy issues I.E Loki Thor Tony Stark
Star-Lord arguably Gamora and nebula
Yelena shung Chi the list literally
really does go on she's team audience
looking out for us asking when the X-Men
are coming he says he can't answer that
right now I like what she's doing here
with the thumbs up and the tongue out
like a silly goose she has some
directions on her season two show which
is a great way to lean in to get in a
new season Once you just address it and
say it out loud maybe you might get it
you know they need to know also keep in
mind Bruce May smash buildings but Jen
smashes Bad Endings
and Matt Murdock
this is like my Baron Zemo dance we're
back at a Mills Retreat and it's
daylight outside all the men that stayed
from the Intelligentsia Meetup event is
now arrested the LA sheriff department
is there probably because this is out of
LA's City's jurisdiction so it's not the
LAPD it's the LA sheriff department and
the dodc is there for a mill Titania is
of course vlogging everything to her
titaniacs and we still presumably don't
know why she's there later Jen still
living at home with her parents
introducing Matt to everyone our gen and
Matt dating soon to be I don't know but
I love this Bruce arrives and he has a
son and this is Scar and Scar has
arrived my dudes I was the one that said
I don't think he's gonna be showing up
look who's here standing behind his dad
like a sad sad brooding child scar is
played by will dusner this gives way
though to all the theories people had
about scar in the series and what might
possibly follow the world war Hulk
storyline now in the comics during
Planet hopeless vanished off Earth and
he landed off the car and met Caira the
old straw they had a son Scar and now
before kyera's death she created cocoon
for scar to keep him safe in which he
emerges from not long after this
happened while Hulk was already on his
way back to Earth to enact revenge for
banishing him off world scar aged
quickly after coming out of that damn
cocoon but as soon as he emerged he came
out of fighter because that's all he
knew and Son of Hulk he goes after
axeman bone Galactus fights his cousin
She-Hulk even going after a Hulk and Son
of Hull he likes to fight you guys he
just fights I don't think we'll
necessarily see all of that but I think
we could get some resentment from Scar
and Hulk not being there for him in his
developing years because why wouldn't
you be we're back outside of the
courthouse in the field reporter that
coined the name She-Hulk stopped Jen for
questioning and we see the courtroom
illustration of Jen stepping and looking
back mirrored here it's also a nod to
the dance lot She-Hulk comic I like that
she says that if you attack harm or
harass innocent people I'm coming for
you and when asked as a superhero lawyer
she says both and I can't wait to see
Jen prosecute by day and kick ass by
Night the show closes with Missy
Elliott's we run this Jen's literally
running this changed her own ending girl
like who does that we've got a couple
new courtroom illustrations there's
princess silk feather wearing a meals
inhibitor Kevin wearing his signature
baseball cap reading she-hulk's first
issue Jen taking Todd to court with low
down dirty Josh sweating behind She-Hulk
we also get our final mid-credits scene
and it's Wong breaking a mill out of
prison so now we can expect to see a
meal and America Chavez at the karmitage
I would have tilled to see Madison in
the background but you know I'll take it
I'll take it I'll take it as is also a
meal ask for the Wi-Fi password just
like strange ass Mardo in the first
Doctor Strange movie oh what's this my
mantra
it's a Wi-Fi password
we're not Savages and that's everything
I spotted in the ninth episode of
She-Hulk follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons while
a new rock star subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love I've had a blast
literally so much fun breaking these
down for you I'm really sad to see it
end but uh
oh God I'm choking and I'll have a blast
breaking down whatever comes my way next
so don't worry I'll be back I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching She-Hulk
Smith
[Music]